[Musique]
tintin deux mois de longue haleine ça va
être dur là-bas j'aurais nuit même
[Musique]
ça a été des émotions et là c'est comme
une pression qui se lâchait de savoir
qu'en faire et mettez les pieds sur
l'avion peut sembler valent au canada
celui qui est dans l'avion c'est le
docteur abdul wali un chirurgien afghan
qu'hélène le selor a connu en
afghanistan lorsqu'elle était en mission
avec les forces canadiennes à kandahar
en 2008
l'été dernier alors que les talibans
prenaient le contrôle du territoire
afghan le docteur who ali a fait comme
des milliers d'autres et tenté de
s'enfuir sans succès
c'est pendant cette période qu'elle aime
le sait leur a décidé avec des collègues
de tenter de sauver son ami médecin et
sa famille
le désir de vouloir aider le dr wali en
fait c'est surtout du fait que lorsqu'on
ne put être côtoyer une personne qui est
un cas comme celui-là qui avait vraiment
le désir de faire beaucoup pour l'eau
pour autrui mais aujourd'hui on sait que
c'est lui qui a besoin de soutien non
maintenant je dois contribuer à aider
d'emprunt cet homme là salut les amis
jusqu'à pas d'âge hélène le seul heure
était à l'époque officiers responsables
des cliniques médicales des forces
canadiennes sur place qui l'avait amené
à rencontrer le docteur roy lee
dr wali est très très inquiet de parler
au téléphone parce qu'à chaque fois
comme il dit je sais pas qui est
autrement entendre pour des raisons de
sécurité la capitaine à la retraite ne
communique avec lui que par texto
cryptée
après avoir raté l'évacuation par avion
à kaboul le docteur who ali a dû
rebrousser chemin avec sa femme et ses
sept enfants vers kandar le plus
discrètement possible
il a ensuite réussi à se rendre dans la
ville frontalière de keita et après des
semaines d'attentes il a pu faire la
longue route en bus avec sa famille vers
la capitale pakistanaise
lui c'est une situation très anxiogène
de se faire dire qu'ils ne bougent plus
nulle part si on veut t'aider on doit
savoir où tu ne peux pas retourner en
afghanistan
maintenant qu'il est à islamabad le
docteur who ali se sent un peu plus en
sécurité
hélène leu seller et son collègue le
lieutenant-colonel luxe un genre aussi
impliqués dans l'opération peuvent enfin
communiquer avec lui par visioconférence
[Musique]
après des mois de démarches et de
recherche tout est en fait en place le
vol d'évacuation vers le canada aura
lieu le lendemain la famille obtient ses
papiers et montent à bord de l'avion
mais sans le docteur roux ali les
autorités pakistanaises tarder à émettre
son permis de sortie sa femme et ses
enfants sont dévastés
dans les jours suivants hélène le
salaire va travailler jour et nuit pour
aider à régler le problème
c'est la georgie
ici on aime ici
ap ap lindsay
[Musique]
feeling ap new life match de poule et
non la
tâche
[Musique]
le docteur wali a pu saluer brièvement
ses enfants à distance dans la cour de
l'hôtel torontois où ils sont maintenus
en quarantaine avant pu avoir la chance
de renouer avec dr moralité d'un une
façon en fait de faire un peu la paix
avec ce qu'on a vécu on a bien la suite
des choses dépendra des autorités
canadiennes mais aussi beaucoup d
efforts de bons samaritains comme il
aime le solaire et ses amis
[Musique]